FIVE."
♪ ♪
♪
>> LIBERAL NEW YORK CITY MAYORS
HITTING A TINY TASTE OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BORDER
PLAN, THE FIRST MIGRANTS
ARRIVING IN NEW YORK CITY FROM
TEXAS, COURTESY OF GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT AND THE IDEAL DESTINATION
ACCORDING TO HIS QUOTE.
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS CLAIMS THAT HIS
CITY IS BEING OVERWHELMED.
BUT ACCORDING TO ABBOTT, THAT IS
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO WHAT THEY ARE
DEALING WITH.
>> PUBLIC OFFICIALS NEED TO
REALIZE THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
CHAOS CREATED BY THE BORDER
POLICIES AND THERE HAVE BEEN
THOUGHTS ABOUT THEM COMING INTO
THE COMMUNITIES OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS, WE HAVE MORE THAN
5000 PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THAT
SECTOR EVERY SINGLE DAY.
SO WE ARE FULL IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
COMMUNITIES ARE OVERRUN AND I
STARTED FUSSING PEOPLE TO
WASHINGTON DC WHEN PEOPLE CANNOT
HANDLE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> MAYOR ADAMS SLAMMING TEXAS
AFTER DECLINING MULTIPLE
INVITATIONS TO WITNESS THINGS
FIRSTHAND.
♪ ♪
♪
>> HE FINALLY ADMITTED WHAT WE
WERE SAYING.
WITH OPEN ARMS, THIS IS WHO WE
ARE IN THE CITY.
WE NEED HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE HAVING A GREAT
CONVERSATION THIS AFTERNOON.
BUT IT HAS BEEN DESPICABLE WHAT
WE ARE DEALING WITH.
>> IF YOU WONDER WHY WE ARE
HAVING A RECORD SURGE AT THE
BORDER, WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE
AMOUNT OF FOOTAGE ON JESSE
WATTERS PRIME TIME.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO JOE
BIDEN?
>> WE ARE COMPLETELY GRATEFUL
FOR HIM GIVING US THE CHANCE FOR
US TO COME HERE.
Jeanine: OKAY, SO I SAW YOU
LAUGHING AS I WAS LAUGHING.
MAYOR ADAMS, I THINK THERE WERE
50 OR SO THEY CAME AND ON ABOUT
AND THEY ARE HAVING A CONNIPTION
FIT OR SO, SAYING THAT THIS IS
ALSO BY GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT.
>> WE ARE WITH THE REALITY OF
WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING FOR A
LONG TIME.
BY THE WAY, THERE ARE MORE
PEOPLE THAT COME ACROSS THE
BORDER IN TEXAS IN A DAY THEN
WHAT WE HAD TODAY.
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS POINT?
MAYOR ADAMS ACCUSED GREG ABBOTT
OF DOING IT BEFORE HE WAS EVEN
DOING IT.
YOU REMEMBER WHEN WE FOLLOWED
THE CLAIM AND IT LANDED IN NEW
YORK CITY, WE FOLLOWED IT IN
JERSEY, THEY CALLED THE POLICE
ON THE CAMERA CREW, AND ALSO IN
WESTCHESTER.
WHEN THEY WERE COMING TO NEW
YORK, THE MIGRANTS, YOU KNOW,
THEY SAID THESE PEOPLE ARE
COMING FROM TEXAS, BUT THEY WERE
NOT COMING FROM TEXAS.
THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS
FLYING THEM IN AND THEN DROPPING
THEM OFF AT LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND SO GREG ABBOTT SAID OKAY, IF
YOU WANT THEM, YOU WANT TO DO
THIS AND HE SHIPPED THEM THERE.
BUT WHAT IT'S DOING RIGHT NOW IS
HIGHLIGHTING THE HYPOCRISY FROM
THE LEFT, THEY WERE ALL ABOUT
COMPASSION AND GIVING HANDOUTS,
SO THEY WERE ON THEIR LINES AND
IT'S IN THIS CONSERVATIVE AREA
WHERE ALL OF THEM HAVE GONE.
AND NOW THEY ARE FACTORED IN,
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT IT.
$80 BILLION NOW, HOW ABOUT YOU
SEND THAT MONEY TO THE BORDER
FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
TRYING TO KEEP US SAFE ON A
DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
Jeanine: YOU KNOW, SANDRA,
THEY ARE A SANCTUARY CITY.
WHY DON'T THEY JUST BEAR THE
BURDEN OF SANCTUARY CITIES
THERE.
>> THE IRONY IS THAT HE TOLD
GREG ABBOTT THAT THE SOLUTION
THAT YOU SHOULD PROVIDE IS
HOUSING FOR THE MIGRANTS.
AND THAT IS WHAT HE OFFERED.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU THINK,
OKAY, IT IS THE IDEA THAT THIS
IS A POLITICAL PLOY FOR A PHOTO
OP.
IN ERIC ADAMS SAYS OKAY, TAKE
THEM IN, DEAL WITH IT THE BEST
THAT YOU CAN, SAYING WHAT ARE
YOU GUYS COMPLAINING ABOUT IN
TEXAS, YOU HAVE TO THINK THAT
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD THAT HE CAN'T
EVEN TAKE CARE OF IT TO SAY HEY,
YOU GUYS ARE NOT DOING IT RIGHT,
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MANAGE IT
HERE.
TALKING ABOUT THESE SIGNIFICANT
SECURITY ISSUES OF THESE BORDERS
AS WELL IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> WHEN THEY ASK ABOUT THE
BORDER, HE MADE A COMMENT TO MY
STANDPOINT AND PLAUSIBLE
STATEMENT, THAT THE BORDER WAS
SECURE FROM HERE FROM YOUR
VANTAGE POINT AND OPINION, IS
THE BORDER SECURE?
>> I THINK THAT THE BORDER
PRESENTS SIGNIFICANT ISSUES,
THERE IS A WIDE ARRAY,
REPRESENTING A SIGNIFICANT
SECURITY ISSUE AND A WIDE ARRAY
OF CRIMINAL THREATS THAT FLOW
OUT OF HERE.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT 50
PEOPLE AS WELL.
>> 1.7 MILLION ENCOUNTERED LAST
YEAR, RIGHT NOW WE ARE ON PACE
TO TAX ACT, SO THIS COULD BE A
PHOTO OP, BUT IT'S NOT THE
REALITY.
>> THE AMAZING PART OF IT,
JESSICA, MAYOR ADAMS ASKED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR HELP AND
THEY SAID NO, DEAL WITH IT.
AND THEN I THINK IT WAS THAT WAS
HER THAT ASKED FOR SOME NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS TO COME IN AND
THEY SAID NO.
SO NOW THEY ARE ALL OF A SUDDEN
EXPERIENCING NOW THAT THEY KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE, WHY ARE THEY
GOING AFTER THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS AS THE PRESIDENT IS
LETTING THEM IN MAKING US ALL
SUFFER?
Jeanine: GOOD IDEA, GO AFTER
YOUR OWN PARTY.
>> THE PRESIDENT CONTROLLING THE
BORDER, HE IS A DEMOCRAT.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT PARTY.
>> I'M TELLING YOU THAT IT IS,
HOLISTICALLY IT IS A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE, AND WITH ALL WITNESSES
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> I JUST EXPLAINED WHY HE WAS
GOING AFTER GOVERNOR ABAY.
>> THERE'S ALSO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THEN AS WELL.
>> POLITICS GOING ON, WE HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I DON'T THINK
IT'S A GOOD THING WHAT IS GOING
ON, ALSO MAYOR ADAMS SAID THAT
WE ARE A WELCOMING CITY AND I
JUST NEED SOME HELP.
THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SHOULD BE PROVIDING THIS.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOR THEM.
WE ARE A SANCTUARY CITY.
THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
NEEDS TO GIVE THE MONEY TO DC
AND NEW YORK, IF YOU THINK THAT
WE HAVE THE JOBS FOR THEM AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN DO THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
[TALKING OVER EACH OTHER]
>> EVERY STATE THAT HAS A
PROBLEM --
>> BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
--
>> BUT WE DO HAVE THE MONEY.
>> WE DON'T NEED AMERICAN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO GIVE TO
THESE CITIES THAT HAVE RECLAIMED
THEMSELVES SANCTUARY CITY SO
THAT THEIR RESIDENCE AND
CONSTITUENTS DON'T FEEL THE PAIN
AND VOTE THEM OUT OF OFFICE
REMAKING THEM A SANCTUARY CITY.
IT'S EASY TO BE A CENTURY CITY
WHERE A THOUSAND PEOPLE SHOW UP
AND NOW YOU ARE OVERRUN?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT
ALL.
WHY IS IT THAT THEY THINK THAT
WASHINGTON DC CANNOT HANDLE THIS
BUT HOUSTON SHOULD.
THIS IS A BIG ISSUE.
GUATEMALA, ANYWHERE ELSE,
HARBORING ANY ILL WILL TOWARD
THEM, THE CITIZENS IN THIS
COUNTRY COME FIRST, THAT'S WHAT
THE SACRIFICE COMES FROM, THAT
IS WHO WE ARE, THAT IS OUR
IDENTITY AND IF THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO BE A PART OF THIS,
THAT OUR POLITICIANS NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN CREATING A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS THEM TO OFFER
THEM OPPORTUNITIES SECOND.
I COME FROM A CITY WHERE I HAVE
SEEN PEOPLE T-BONED SOMEONE AND
THEN RUN OFF LIKE MY SISTER.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT MAKES THEM A
GOOD OR BAD PERSON, IT'S OUR
GOVERNMENT FOR LETTING THEM DO
THAT.
THERE IS AN INTRICATE SYSTEM FOR
BRINGING SOMEONE IN AND YOU SAY
COME BACK IN TWO YEARS, THEY'VE
HAD THREE IDENTITIES IN THOSE
TWO YEARS, THAT IS WHAT THE
FROGS US.
IT'S NOT ABOUT EMPATHY.
IT IS ABOUT OH, MAN, NOW IT'S MY
PROBLEM AND NOW I COULD BE
POLITICALLY HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
WE BETTER DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO DO THIS ARE
THOSE THAT COME ILLEGALLY AND
LIVE IN THE SHADOWS AND NEVER
HAD A CHANCE TO BE A PART OF
WHAT IS THE AMERICAN DREAM,
BECAUSE OUR GOVERNMENT, BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, WOULD RATHER
TREAT THIS IN THE WAY THAT THEY
HAVE.
>> WHAT SHOULD JOE BIDEN DO?
>> HE SHOULD GIVE OUT FEDERAL
FUNDS TO PLACES WHERE MIGRANTS
ARE GOING, WORK ON BORDER
SECURITY.
LAST WEEK THEY STARTED CLOSING
OFF THE BIG GAP.
>> THE LAST TIME THAT WE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION YOU SAID THAT
GREG ABBOTT DID NOT WORK.
>> THAT'S WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT A DIFFERENT TOPIC.
[TALKING OVER EACH OTHER]
>> NOW IT HAS BECOME A NATIONAL
STORY IN ALL OF THE CITIES NOW.
>> OKAY, GUYS.
>> THEY ARE TREATING MIGRANTS AS
IF THEY ARE TOYS.
>> HOW ABOUT YOU GO CLOSE THE
BORDER.
>> JOE BIDEN IS THE ONE WHO IS
TREATING THEM AS THOUGH THEY
NEED TO BE PROTECTED.
THAT THEY NEED HELP, MEDICATION,
EVERYTHING ELSE, WHILE WE PAY
FOR THE NOSE FOR IT.
NEW YORK CITY CAN AFFORD